in the back woods and swamps of Arkansas
there is a legend of something
terrifying on God happen
I guess you could say that we're looking
for the boggy creek creature but when
you search for alleged
[Music]
you may not like what you find because
it may be coming later when you least
expect
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and welcome back to the show
13 o'clock Tom and Jane and it's episode
42 collection of cryptids we have not
done a cryptid show yet
Jenny calm she didn't really want to do
a cryptid show but well I didn't until I
started researching it yeah because I
think when we first started talking
about doing a cryptid show I was like
man I don't want to do a whole show
about Bigfoot yawn
there's more than that out but yeah then
we decided well let's just see one about
like all the Crypt is and that'll be
like way more fun because there's way
more fun ones out there and you know
let's go and get this out of way many of
these crooked czar implausible but there
are a few that are plausible yeah I
don't know if you put the plausible ones
on this list did you well I kind of put
plausible ones and batshit crazy okay
just to get you know entertainment fact
yeah because I thought you know so I
just put ones that I thought were
interesting because I said I can't talk
about like every crap that ever
remarried because the show will be like
9 hour long this show is at least rooted
in reason and some of the members that
are there relatively but you know this
could be the show yeah it'll be fun and
you know I did a lot of research and
picked out some of the some of the more
plausible crypt ISM than some of the
crazier wants to is some of the ones I
thought were cool okay that's what we're
going to talk about and I kind of have
them all in categories and all that I
have keepa do plugs
alright so the first thing yeah so the
first thing we got to say as we always
do big thank you to the project
Entertainment Network on which our audio
podcast is hosted um you guys are just
doing fantastic or last month we had
four times more downloads than we had
the previous one yeah Clark May which
quadrupled our numbers were quadrupled
we're now a number two yeah we're now
their second second biggest shows of
woohoo thank you guys that's pretty
awesome yeah and also uh for the people
that are listening to the podcast please
subscribe to our YouTube channel so yeah
even if you don't listen to it on there
subscribe to it so we can get credit for
it and we know how many of you guys
there are
and it's also a way that if you ever
want to make a request or you ever need
to contact us it's very easy to leave a
comment on youtube yeah
and we and we always read those we
probably read those more than we read
the messages on the blogs and everything
yeah so we'll see that one probably
sooner right also I want to thank
everybody that has bought my book the
unseen hand it's selling really good
especially the audio book version yeah
the audio book it's weird audio book
just came out of nowhere yeah yeah I
thought maybe we would really dominate
on eBook aa-are you know I'm on at the
audio so which is good man everybody
loves it yeah and you've got a new
review from Australia yeah a five-star
review on that they loved it then I
think you've got a review on that in
England now that yeah maybe but I was
yes I really but yeah I really have to
appreciate all the people that listen
that that contacted us from England and
Australia after with free stuff that
contact us yes so free so same thing I
mean if you guys I still have some codes
left
I have codes for unseen hand I have
codes for my other Nam mammoth mountain
poltergeist Rochdale poltergeist house
entire whispers all my for paranormal
book I still have codes for all of those
so I'm just all you only week yeah
that's audio little Elvis lettuce we
would love to give out free samples of
eBook and print book but the companies
don't allow us to do it yeah pretty much
um ACS food that that's the parent
company of audible as they they're the
only ones that kind of let me do that
every time I publish a book they send me
you know X amount of codes that I can
give to people you know to you know to
kind of get interest going and get
people to write reviews and things like
that because you know it's good for them
good for me so so that's generally what
they're for and I usually try to give
them out to get people to write reviews
so if you want to write a brief review
of it any like I said any one of the
four paranormal books I still have code
I don't have a lot left for unseen hands
but I have some for the other ones so if
you want those then let me know contact
me somehow on YouTube or Facebook or
wherever you know over Twitter or
whatever yeah and Australia and the UK
have priority on yes but if it is we
under be really we find as true is just
so we have lots of reviews on the u.s.
article we need to fill in the holes
of Australia is very lacking if there's
anybody from Australia will verify
through Facebook you know where you're
coming from so we so we know you
actually live in Australia but any book
you want any audiobook you want will
send you a code for ya
and let's see you name was English yes
that's right so um oh and also if you
like my paranormal stuff my paranormal
nonfiction I did an interview on the
real paranormal activity podcast with
Erin hunter and that was posted about a
week ago I think so if you go to the
real paranormal activity podcast just
you know do a google search on it and
find it I think I was either episode 123
or 124 I came over now but um but yet
it'll have my name on there so if you
want to go listen to me talk about my
new book and about poltergeist in
general then you can do that also
spooky Empire I think we've mentioned
that before it's coming up in October
it's actually the weekend before
Halloween October 27th 28th to 29th and
we are going to be there live in person
yeah with blues dude not really not yeah
with booze though we're going to be on
most of the panel's we're going to be
like most the literary panel and I think
we're hosting the the sick and twisted
panel they're just the best one yeah
that's what we really Friday night yeah
that's when we hand out free booze yeah
yeah and that's the one where everybody
talks about like the most fucked-up [ __ ]
ik and yeah thank you have them stuff
like that so yeah that's a usually their
most popular one a year so yeah we're
going to be at that one and we're gonna
be you know and we'll be around to look
during the weekend to what selling books
will be on a table doing meet-and-greet
and whatnot okay I also want to do
another shout out I ran I stumbled into
something I like to be the hip
connection so if I run into something
cool on my tell everybody even if it's
like if it doesn't necessarily have to
be new or anything like that this is
just stuff we happen to randomly come
across yeah I don't know about you guys
I'm a Star Trek fan I'm not a big fan of
like the newer Star Trek with JJ Abrams
I really didn't even really like
next generation pretty much but I love
the original series with Kirk and Spock
well they got some guys that are making
old old-school Star Trek with Kirk and
Spock and it's a dead ringer and it's
guys making it there it's a fan their
fan films but you wouldn't know it
really by looking at the real pro and
it's called Star Trek continues and you
can watch it free on YouTube
it's got Grant Imahara on it yeah from
mythbuster on mythili Sulu Lou Ferrigno
shows up as Olin alien as an Orion slave
master it's really cool and they also
had the the chick from Aaron gray yeah
from Buck Rogers that's right Obama
yep she was the guy who makes this stuff
he does he plays Kirk in this little
miniseries and he just got it man's a
dead ringer it's awesome go check it out
it's like yeah and it's like I'm kind of
the same I didn't really care about like
anything new or like next generation or
voyage or anything but the original
series that's my jam it's like I love
Spock he's the best you know I'm not
like a super super fan but you know I'm
pretty into their original series and
this thing like we just discovered it
and he's like yeah McKenney Jenny honey
you got to see this and then like we
just sat there all day and like watched
every single episode there was up like
you see if they have eight episodes
there's three more and then three more
they'll be out in here they're not gonna
make any more of them yeah because
there's some licensing stuff going on
now where I am but just with making fan
films which making fan films and stuff
you're not really you you can make them
you're just not allowed to make profit
off them which these people don't they
have that they actually have a
non-profit and that's what they make it
out of and actually he put up he fronted
his own money to make yeah there's ones
and then you get did a Kickstarter to
one hundred and fifty thousand dollars
of his own money in it but anyway I
think one of the strongest things is
when you look at it it looks like Star
Trek it was a really original 60s Star
Trek yeah the lighting the framing of
the shots just let everything looks
exactly the special effects are a little
bit better but it's but the set is
exactly the steps are exactly like it so
the costumes and the writing
surprisingly the writing is really
really good each episode is very if
we're very very tricky and I really like
I think it was the fourth episode and I
don't know if you guys remember the
mirror episode where there was the evil
Spock with the beard yeah
or that like the most famous yeah and
then Kirk left him behind and goes back
to his own dimension I was wanted what
that bearded Spock that did what he did
back to start the revolution and they
actually have an episode for that and
gets up so forth and Men just if you're
only going to watch one of them watch
that one
we'll get the name of that one do you
know man now I can't remember it
something like and better than all
fairest of them all set that's it one
yeah I'll prepare your only to watch one
of them well it's like a continuation of
miramare yeah oh it's awesome yeah
okay so actually we're almost at the
10-minute mark so let's get on with the
cryptids yeah okay so what I did
basically so we're going to talk about
cryptids and we're kind of talking about
you know ones that are plausible ones
people have seen ones that maybe you're
a little bit less plausible that are
maybe just kind of legend or whatever I
kind of felt like we should start with
the kind of bigger-ticket ones and then
like after the commercial break we can
do kind of a weird or more than that you
might put a slash step 7 right right
member yeah so the first thing we wanted
to talk about we wanted to start with
you know you're big you Bigfoot because
that's probably I think that's probably
one of the most commonly reported at
least in this country I'm not sure about
other places but kind of one of the most
commonly reported types of cryptids big
yeah they're pretty universal kind of
dragons yeah they ran usually yeah
pretty much every kinda has foreign
culture had one and usually usually
described as like either like a big
gorilla type looking guy or like a
Neanderthal usually between six or ten
feet tall they're usually bigger than a
person they usually have reddish or
brown or black fur they usually smell
bad
not always but usually and there's
different ones like some of them tend to
be aggressive and attack people some of
them not so much like some of our more
shy and stuff like that
obviously the most popular one Bigfoot
slash Sasquatch kind of spotted all over
but I think most mostly concentrated on
the Pacific Northwest is where he's
vamos no man would also yeah yeah but
the thing about Bigfoot and Sasquatch is
that pretty much every region of the
United States has their own version rut
right like here in Florida we have the
skunk ape or the stinky he's also called
the city for obvious reasons
I don't cuz that's that's what I call
him I call him that I don't
skycam if you understood the Florida
Panhandle you know what where these
storage account just look like that
Laura Panhandle blood truckin you'll see
so yeah so we have skunk ape also if you
guys and if you're like me and our
mystery science theater fan and it
seemed boggy creek too and the legend
continues which is actually one of my
favorite episodes there's also the boggy
creek monster that is an actual
bigfoot-type creature that's reported in
Arkansas also called the fook monster or
Falcom on stir I'm not sure you
pronounce that
it looks like [ __ ] monster but they're
not better that's something totally
different yeah or the southern Sasquatch
is also called that now Louisiana has
one called the honey island swamp
monster which is gray and he has webbed
feet so I don't know why I guess oh
because I guess it's Louisiana yeah it's
like swampy but it's what we hear you
know now thanks gunk a PEZ yeah better
swamps and swamps in New Orleans and
nothing compared to the swamps here
that's true well it lets me down the
Everglades yeah and then Ohio has one
called the grassman Arizona has one
called the Mogollon monster McGowen
something I don't know so you just don't
even have all off yeah these are just
like the US one alright there's one
called Lobo the monster that's in
Missouri he has like a big pumpkin head
in Ontario they have one called old
yellow top who's like Bigfoot except he
has like a blonde streak in his hair
yeah he's like the hip Bigfoot with the
frosted hair and these have been
reported like all over the world so
obviously most obvious one in Nepal is
the Yeti which is kind of like Bigfoot
but he's kind of usually depicted with
white fur not always Teddy Roosevelt to
even claim to seen a Bigfoot well in a
way a lot of people have said they were
thick but he told a story that he was
around a campfire and there was some
kind of big moving object out there
threw a stone at him threw a stone at
their campfire and I think he threw the
stone back and it gave out a while how
its evolving today I think he was
alluding to it was a it was a big it was
a Bigfoot yeah now see of all the
cryptids like I'm not sure I really buy
any of them existing like other than the
ones that are just like you know big
bats or whatever you know that could
exist obviously but of all the kind of
real hardcore cryptids I think Bigfoot
is the most likely one to exist or
bigfoot-type
not that I'm saying they do yeah I'm
just saying that it would surprise me
the least here's the problem with
Bigfoot Bigfoot type creatures
especially in North America most of
North America of the United States has
roads when I'm through it yeah if you
look at Google Earth pretty much no
matter where I drop you on the United
States if you walk in one direction
being longer than about an hour or so
you hit a road yeah so that means
there's going to be Bigfoot's crossing
roads I just don't think that there's a
habitat for them in most of the
continental United States if a Bigfoot
does exist in the continental United
States it's going to be up somewhere
around like Washington State yeah and a
big National Forest I mean some of those
national forests man is still not set up
yet yeah somewhere where no one goes or
no no sale or a very long time right if
it exists it's going to be there it's
not going to something like Florida's
Kincaid it could not remain hidden in
Florida well because like you said and
this is kind of a problem that arises
with a lot of crypts is not just Bigfoot
is that there has to be a lot of them
like for people to see it all there has
to be a breeding finally a breeding
population means that there's a lot of
which means there has to be a lot of it
which means there's going to be an
environmental impact yeah here's an
example we live in Sanford Florida which
is a relatively civilized place this is
a higher income housing Jenny and I have
looked at our back window and saw a
brown black bear climbing the fences
yeah I was working on my motorcycle and
felt like someone's watching me looked
at and looked out my garage door and
there was a bear looking around the
corner at me going hey you got any food
yeah you know and they've run away
they're like a dog yeah they run through
our neighborhood all the day so Bigfoot
would have been the same way and we
lived probably like less than a my like
a mile from the highway yeah they're
everywhere like for my four and a few
years back a neighbor well some neighbor
you know the UH down here by this
anyway where the barn was yeah okay the
guy who owns the doctor that owns that
farm trapped a bobcat
yeah there's Bobcat all through here you
never see him yeah that's a nighttime
creature but they're here yeah and
there's an environmental impact they all
leave trails behind and footprints
behind if there were Bigfoot there'd be
a breeding population you'd see them and
they'd be living leaving footprints
everywhere yeah some of the newer
paranormal cliques that you'll find
online are claiming that Bigfoot is a
spiritual creature almost like a ghost
like I'm like a Native American ghost
but they're spinning it in that
direction to explain why there is a lack
of footprints and why there is a lack of
physical evidence although some people
have claimed to obtain footprints or
have those plaster casts but they're
very easy to fake that's the only thing
yeah like I could make I could make a
plaster cast of a Bigfoot that all you
have to do is cut one out of a piece of
cardboard not saying there's no Bigfoot
see I know there's no Bigfoot around
here no no no there was a Bigfoot in the
continental United States it would be up
near Washington State Sierra Nevada
mountains maybe up near Canada in the
Canada area oh yeah that's the only
place where that could wear something
like yeah it would have we way it's way
way out in the wilderness and then with
the advent of flare and all these weird
satellite technology you might be able
to actually pick up a you cannot go to
pick up a Yeti something that big body
heat from space at night yeah you think
yeah maybe maybe they're not looking for
it yeah one of the ones you do one of
the ones in this category that I think
that I think is plausible because there
were some pretty good witnesses to it
witnesses that were educated was the
orang pendeks
yeah the o-ring pendick might exist yeah
that was actually that's been seen in
the Sumatra and that's and the thing
about the Orion can bag is kind of like
Bigfoot in the sense that it's like an
ape-like creature but it's not big it's
only it's usually described between two
and five feet tall right which is just
the size of like a normal a four normal
monkey pretty much it could be like an
orangutan or so yeah
driving is like a very bipedal chimp
chimp sized orangutan yeah kinda what
which that wouldn't that wouldn't shock
me if there was some kind of other
primate out the Bandit every that was
that sighs that's all a Bigfoot or an
o-ring pan deck is gonna be though it's
nothing supernatural it's nothing well
yeah we could be it would just be an
island private yeah so it's probably
what it would be and you know the
gorilla was an unknown primate for a
long time right then I was that exists
yeah and I think a lot of people point
that out when they're talking about
Bigfoot and stuff like that but you know
there were other kind of smaller ones
like there was one called the Batu toot
or the rock ape which was seen in
Vietnam Laos and Borneo and that was
actually probably seen by the US
soldiers during during the Vietnam War
you know there's other ones too like
some of the most interesting ones I
thought these hipot and actually these
have been reported in Alaska and the
funny thing about these is that there's
actually it's not just one creature this
is like two populations of creatures
they're almost like competing right
because there's one that are like kind
of regular but um you know bigfoot-type
creatures called it Uryu Lee and they're
real they're ten feet tall and they have
a cry that smells like a loon and they
have like luminescent eyes of really
long arms and stuff like that but
they're really peaceful they're shy they
keep to themselves and stuff like that
and they were reported in south east of
southwestern Alaska rather now in south
eastern Alaska there's another creature
that's said to be like their rivals or
something like that
they're called the kushtaka now these
are not these are kind of like Bigfoot
creatures but they're more like
man-sized like where otters they're like
yeah they're like Bigfoot's the day of
like otter heads okay which I don't know
whatever a medieval dog hit yeah kinda
and they're supposed to like eat
children and stuff like that but
honestly of all the Bigfoots hikers now
I really don't think this one exists but
of all the bigfoot-type creatures the
coolest one that I discovered and maybe
I don't know if you've heard of this
because you grew up in Brazil but um
have you ever heard of them mapinguari
no the mapinguari
he's also called the is naxi and he's
kind of like a Bigfoot except and he's
reported like around the rainforests of
like Brazil and Bolivia and stuff like
that now he supposedly is like a Bigfoot
but he only has
one-eye yeah now he has really long
claws like a sloth like a ground sloth
and he kind of lizardy skin and he has
backwards feet which is something that a
lot of well that's something that a lot
of people report about like yetis and
things like that so they have backwards
feet so it's like you can't tell where
they're going Yakko so you can't track
more than one had that and also he has a
second belly in his tummy so there's two
stomachs hands down no he has like a
mouth in his stuff was like right yeah
okay that you said he had another belly
in his belly belly ception
no he knows about okay maybe I did say
that I don't it's not that almost sounds
because you have a nice monster that's
what I was thinking I was like that's
very weird that only yokai yeah it
sounds like a yokai I felt like okay
okay so I mean other than bigfoot-type
creatures was a ton of those there's
some other kind of like hominid type
creatures that I kind of wanted to get
into a little bit and one of these that
was really cool
just cuz I like the name of it is a puck
hua ji [ __ ] Wu ji and this comes from
the Wampanoag Indians what sounds like
something that you do to freshman here
at high no give him the [ __ ] bloody
mister from like Massachusetts Native
American now this is supposed to be a
little hominid he's only 2 to 3 feet and
he's kind of gray and he has like a big
nose and big fingers and big ears but
they have magical powers okay they can
whatever go yeah they can conjure fire
they can appear and disappear control
the souls of people they've killed I
don't know how to kill Bailey zoo
I don't know they killed me like I say
set them on fire which you know that's
bad the Native American leprechaun it's
a Native American leprechaun pretty much
just because and this kind of reminded
me of it too just because I guess
because he was gray and little but in
1973 there was a creature spotted in
Illinois and he's called the Enfield
monster no relation to the Enfield
poltergeist which we also did a show on
it's a completely different thing but
the person that saw this reported it as
a four and a half foot tall creature
that
gray skinned he has three legs - little
short arms and two big huge pink eyes
like flashlights and I'm like what the
[ __ ] was he said it hits like a wildcat
right and that it could jump really high
and like jump really far now the first
guy that saw that he thought it was an
alien but skeptics later that looked
into it saw it well it might be some
kind of monkey or a kangaroo that
escaped from a zoo or something like
that so nobody knows what that was but
that was kind of another humanoid one
from Illinois and now like right around
the same like kind of Midwest Michigan
and Ohio kind of area and maybe some of
you guys have heard of this I think I
saw non mysteries at the museum
the melon heads have you ever heard of
the melon head Gilligan just in Michigan
for a while - the melon heads are
supposedly these obviously people with
big huge bulbous head and apparently
there's a whole bunch of them and they
live out around this mansion called salt
mansion in Michigan the legends are
different about them in every state but
usually it has to do with them being
children with hydrocephalus who had been
experimented on by some evil doctor or
something like that and then they either
escaped or they were let go and they
went feral and then they started living
out in the woods and breeding and things
like that and now they they either eat
babies or they eat people that go into
the woods around there that's weird cuz
I had an ex-girlfriend in Boston a long
time ago and it was Stephanie and she
was from place called she was from LA
not Massachusetts but works over there
you think of the other statements up
near there anyway she told me something
but these Apple had children and it kind
of kind of it might be the same thing
because because ring inbred children
from a little housing complex and the
housing complex got shut down or nobert
they put a fence around it first by the
government and then it got shut down and
then there were these people
inbred children living out in the woods
trying to capture kids that I think
that's the same she believed it she
thought it was real they were older lost
there's a version of it from Connecticut
to
okay wasn't Connecticut but there but
that's kind of the three states there
it's Michigan Ohio Connecticut our main
seat they're called Melonhead Pro I'll
maybe I'll remember but yeah they're all
there's all kinds of variations of that
but they all usually have two good
Hampshire she was from the hand okay so
it might be they're probably the same
yeah it was helpful with applehead
children or Apple children or something
like that it had something dude there
was an apple orchard nearby and he would
pick apples and sell make apple pies
himself to the Fatah and she told me the
story as if it were real if any
listeners know what the hell I'm talking
about yeah make that like I said that
might be another variation the melon
legend because I've heard of the melon
heads I haven't heard appleheads but it
sounds like the shiny bring it to be
true but you telling me that story that
I remembered that that's pretty funny
yeah her story is similar man I'm gonna
have to look at my head yeah Apple had
children I think it's what she said or
yeah go ahead something missing from New
Hampshire New Hampshire was once it was
strange I never been I've been I'm in
the well but I felt like I stuck out
there why is it by people off of money
you know
hahaha looks like people often love it
yeah it's like I got back in time and
everything is black and white it's weird
okay if any of our New Hampshire lizards
know what the hell he's talking about
please tell me I'm a Florida native I
have no idea dashes like a parallel
universe I was only there for a day or
two so yeah I had to go through it too
weird play a Walmart and everybody was
staring at it
maybe they thought if I ever ended in de
armas or something there was something
about oh there was they looked very like
Pennsylvania Dutch or something that
something was weird about oh my god
that's a fair call I felt like I was
from another planet you are oh look
there's an outsider okay all right now
should now see okay now in my because we
went on so long about the about that
melon heads and about the Bigfoot
creatures I was actually going to talk
about I was going to start talking about
like lake monsters well I'm on the break
but maybe we should wait until after the
break and get into lake monsters and
then this show is probably going to run
a little bit late anyway we have
maybe yeah we sell a bunch of stuff but
you know if it does you know whatever it
doesn't matter so I'll say I'll actually
we're getting up to the halfway point so
take a break right now we can kind of go
over the lake monsters and then get into
the fun stuff okay all right so we'll be
back in just a few minutes is uh it's
Kazan Buzard we're the two PI's and
hosted by me mr. Frank the song is the
Toki's podcast for bizarro fiction genre
and those are right weird and reappeared
are going to love this behind anyone in
the bazaar and we are clicking thrill so
join us here every Monday presented
exclusively by the project entertainment
[Music]
subculture corsets in clothing is our
favorite store for unusual clothing
shoes and accessories they offer a wide
selection of men's and women's clothing
at great prices so culture also offers
the cool selection of shoes and
accessories steampunk gothic apparel
retro corsets and so much more at
subculture corsets and clothing
check out subculture online at
subculture corsets calm that subculture
corsets calm make sure you use the
discount code 13 o'clock for a 10%
discount subculture corsets calm or
visit their store in jacksonville
florida just off i-95 how do people who
make stuff up for a living make stuff up
New York Times best seller Jonathan
Mayberry told us all Oprah's Book Club
favorites
sue Miller tomodea we sort of take a
character and make some bad things
happen have we have time to do that we
colored them just like at a cocktail
party except to your head so join us
every Thursday for the liar's club odd
cat a slightly unhinged podcast where
storytellers interview other storyteller
available on project Entertainment
Network iTunes and everywhere podcasts
are heard
[Music]
[Music]
okay and we're back lake monsters now a
while back we did a show on sea monsters
and ghost ships and the sea monster show
we kind of covered you you know you
Kraken G giant squid you're octopuses
and stuff like that size want you know
the lake monster thing those are usually
like Nessie yeah they're usually like a
like a long snake thing or like a
plesiosaur type of thing and again just
like in Bigfoot it seems like
everybody's got one right like every
significant body of water has a lake
monster and it's got it here in the
United States we have them here in the
United States usually between 10 and 80
feet long you know some of them are
bigger than others you know obviously
Loch Ness monster is the most famous but
the US has a bunch of them and
interestingly most of the American ones
are usually based off Native American
legends that's usually where they
started from like the Native American
settlers later or they claim that they
were they explain that I don't think
those stories are as old as this day
might not be today they might not be
yeah so us we have a there's a monster
living in Lake Champlain called champ or
champion on originally and that's that
said it's been cited to see 1,600
there's one in Georgia living in the
Altamaha River there's one in the Bear
Lake River between Utah and Idaho that
one actually has legs 50 feet long and
he's usually described as cream-colored
with a head like a cow so not so much
like the plesiosaur type model is more
like a kind of dragony looking thing
Lake Erie has Bessie Chesapeake Bay has
chessy Lake Tahoe has Tahoe Tessie no
because no one could think of anything
other than Nessie relays some have
noticed already these are all American
reboots of the original of the original
original is Nessie the Loch Ness monster
pretty much when you really look at the
Loch Ness case and the situation of the
Loch Ness all the other ones kind of
fall apart if you ask me yes if there
are any lake monsters you want to go
look at this fishing program River
Monsters those are the lake monsters
well yeah
Jeremie way Jeremy Wade that's scarier
yd need a mint one yeah there's some big
there's some big fish have you present
some of those catfish he's caught or
those arapaima or whatever right there
only fat yeah there are a huge
freshwater fishing lakes that the other
person would wouldn't know where there
so much stuff waste left five six
hundred pounds yeah
pretty connected swallow a man yeah well
some of them do yes mom do I mean that's
that's the whole premise of his show is
that he sees in the newspaper hey
somebody was probably killed by a huge
giant fish run and he goes to check it
out so yeah I think they do see Lake
Monsters every now and then but it's not
messy it's these big fish yeah probably
I mean I'm s because you know like you
said the ones he's caught on there or
horrifying enough and I can totally see
how if you were out and it does for
something like that you know one of
those coming out of the water yeah right
your imagination might run wild oh yeah
with you but if you look at Loch Ness
that's a good story but there's a lot of
ecological problems you got to go back
to where there's hat there has to be a
breeding population yeah because nothing
could be very large yeah if there's a
breeding population that means that
there are many of them and if there are
many of them there has to be a food
source
well I'm Nast doesn't really have any
food not really it's it's very cold and
cold it's deep not much vegetation on
the bottom oh there's not enough food in
there to support of breeding populations
or large creatures like that and if
there were a breeding population of
large creatures as described the young
would be up in the shallows splashing
around for all for everyone to see that
you know big big creatures don't hide
they don't need to hide yeah you know I
often still hi yeah you think and I mean
actually there's one like Nessie type
creature supposedly in Canada they also
they have Ogopogo they also have I go
Pogo that supposedly lives in Lake
Simcoe in Ontario and that one also has
a doglike head but that one's actually
been seen lying on the shore which means
that oh it can breathe air they think
it's not a lake monster but that's
actually a kind of a variation because
they said yeah they've seen that one
laying on the beach rather than just in
the water yeah you know we live in the
south you hear about something like
Nessie and then we look back into the
into
the history of the south Nessie wouldn't
really be all that scary to us there
used to be a alligator guard here that
are fantastically huge you had to make
machines in the early 1900s to go out
there and kill all the GAR they wiped a
lot of a lot yeah because they thought
the guard were dangerous the guard
weren't dangerous though for the most
part they had a lot of teeth they were
long yeah thanks for most things got the
about 10 12 feet long yeah there was a
time in the 1950s where they would
eventually they would pull up snapping
turtles
some of them win you know like five 600
pound snapping turtle yeah six foot in
diameter
nobody sure how old those turtle were
maybe 150 years old that's all gone now
but there used to be big monsters yeah
but you'd recognize them for what they
were they were turtles and big fish I
think the biggest gar I ever saw here
was probably only 5 or 60 I used to
catch him with my dad the biggest one
I've ever caught and this is back in the
very early 80s was about 5 feet long
yeah that's probably the biggest one
I've talked about it then about a foot
and a half long about a foot and a half
of that length with head yeah I got a
big long snout like an alligator yeah
but they're not a very strong fish they
don't fight very hard on the end of a
pole and they don't taste good so you
just throw them back the problem is is
that you can't get a hook out of their
mouth they swallow it every time and to
reach in there to get the hook but you
can't because of all those sharp teeth
so a lot of times you just have to cut
the line or you have to pry the jaws
open to get the hook out and it kills
the fish so every time you got one with
poor things on the end of the on the end
of your line you had to kill it to get
the hook out of it it was sad
so I don't think they have big ones like
they used to anymore now there's so much
development now I don't really think we
have big anything anymore you know as
far as like and it's funny because Loch
Ness the Loch Ness monster is the most
famous one but it's funny because
Scotland actually has another Loch Ness
monster called the Morag that's kind of
their second most famous creature and
supposedly that one was struck by a boat
in 1969 and a guy shot at it but that
was like two witnesses and there's also
one in Ireland called monkey and that
legend only only came about pretty
recently because the lakes of Killarney
they were doing sonar readings in it and
they got this weird like big
anomalous shape and this was in 2003 and
from that this whole legend spiders ol
maybe it's a lake monster so they called
it monkey from the lakes of Killarney
that's Ireland you know on that they're
all pretty much kind of the same and I
think they all kind of come from the
same well you know like you said there's
big fish out there there's lines of
otters there's things like that
guarantee the Loch Ness monster story is
an old story and it really probably
comes against private actually probably
comes from stuff that was handed down
from the medieval period because many
the medieval technology in Europe what
they didn't have the fishing technology
they needed to really bring in big fish
and Jeremy Wade showed it on some of his
programs they didn't medieval times in
Europe some of those fish and those lake
got huge they showed wood cutting so
people said no it can't be true the fish
can't be that big sitting next to a to a
cow but no it could he go down there and
catch him it wasn't a catfish was it big
old grouper it might have been well I
have seen grippers that were almost as
big as a cow yeah I think I've weighed
about a thousand pounds yeah let me
swallow man yeah and Jeremy Wade said
back in the medieval era they didn't
have the fishing tackle you need that
you needed well yeah I think they're
going to be able to fish like sailfish
used to gets a lot bigger bigger bigger
and bigger and bigger needed to really
get their hands on fish that size until
they started draining some of those
small lakes yeah
then they'd find those fish eat oh yeah
sometimes they come up with the netting
technology you needed were a whole bunch
of guys are going to cast a net into a
certain part of the lake and pull on the
net you know huge ropes you know and
maybe you could pull out a fish that big
but you couldn't do it with rod and reel
they didn't really have rotten reel then
yeah yeah yeah
so that [ __ ] got bigger but a fish got
bigger yeah because we never having
would never happen today in modern day
are being taken out of the gene pool if
you look at modern gear up today in
Google Earth that's not the kind of
place where fish would get that big no
like I said too much you development
yeah but you know the other than the
Nessie type creatures I think really the
only kind of you know famous um you know
lake monsters you know they're kind of
well none or the kelpies but they're
more like they're more like horse people
but they're like shapeshifters that you
live as like a Scottish Gaelic thing
yeah
and pretty much it's kind of its kind of
like Loch Ness where it's like every big
lake in Scotland has also has a kelpy
story but they're usually portrayed like
having a horse head or a person with
hooves or something like that
so speaking of like we're creatures and
werewolves and things like that that's
kind of like another very large category
yeah of cryptids your wolf like
creatures a dog like creatures your user
those are Roman in origin I think the
oldest probably and the oldest count of
one was old Roman story about a Roman
soldier killed somebody while in dog
form and escaped forgot how exactly had
a story went but based on memory that
was the first because I didn't know you
were going to mention those but based on
memory that was the first account of a
werewolf was Roman yeah and I think that
kind of stuck with the medieval and only
reason why I think werewolf stories and
shape-shifting stories continue for as
long as they did that they would
occasionally find dead women and
children partially nod then they find
human teeth marks on and in in the
thinking of those days you know I me and
they would say oh well human could have
never done that
that was a vampire or a werewolf that
killed that person a demon that took
human form and because they didn't
really know anything about serial
killers yeah they had a very feelers
then you know yeah they actually
captured one I think it might have in
France who had killed a bunch of girls
he claimed to be a werewolf yeah that
was a pretty famous case yeah Church
killed him eventually I believed in that
I think so yeah I'd have to look it up
but I know I know the guy you're talking
about them so werewolves and vampires
actually I think you could you could
trace it's just serial killers that's
what they're talking about yeah it might
be I mean I'm pretty sure yeah the thing
is it's usually with how the human mind
would work yeah I think the medieval
Christians couldn't grasp the idea of a
serial killer yeah maybe not like I said
won't worry about if you did something
evil in the medieval times if you did
something evil they would say the devil
did it but it got into you yeah so if a
man is a serial killer another
interpretation a medieval interpretation
was that he's possessed by a demon he
turns into an animal he kills me
yeah so in their minds that person
actually physically transforms into that
animal yeah yeah but uh you know that's
what I'm that's what I'm seeing yeah and
like I said you know the ancient
Egyptians had all that human animal
hybrid thing going on to its own you
know I'm pretty sure that that's you
know that's enough pretty much a human
Universal like thinking human can take
in the medieval is also believed in dog
heads they believe the church believe
that dog heads were real and that a dog
had could convert to Christianity and
they'd never seen him yeah and if you
guys don't know the dog head as you can
google it yeah the medieval had
tapestries and drawing the dog heads
that's with a human with a dog head they
believe that they actually existed in
town somewhere over there he's always
somewhere over there they never really
could find it oh yeah over there all
kids in it
yeah that's like your urban legend type
thing and there were actually they were
actually a couple more recent uh you
know since the storm go werewolf there's
a couple of recent cryptid sightings of
those and one of those was Wisconsin the
beast of Bray Road yeah that was spotted
in 1936 although some people thought
that that was more like a Bigfoot but
other witnesses said it was like a like
a werewolf or like a man bear type of
thing and there's bear pee I made a
better figure and then there was one in
1887 that was in Michigan that's a
Michigan Dogman and that was kind of
like that was described pretty much like
a werewolf
yeah like yellow or amber eyes and you
know a how old he had the torso of a man
and like the head of a wolf or whatever
and he supposedly comes on a 10-year
cycle I don't come to do what I don't
know rip people Barnum presumably and
then there are some other ones that are
just like not necessarily world which is
like big wolves or bears or bear wolf
hybrids or like ones that are bigger
than normal you know like the whoa Gila
that's from Canada Canada Michigan Laska
era and there's one called the shunka
we're racking kind of like a Native
American type thing and you know while
we're talking about kind of dogs and
things like that you know we got to
bring out the chupacabra
yeah she's become a chupacabra which you
know every picture I've ever seen of
like I suppose chupacabra it just looks
like a dog with no hair every time I
remember the supercoppa story as it
I'm old enough to remember it yeah as a
development of media at the ship acaba
actually got better as it went along
eventually it became an alien looking
creature with spine but fines on it yeah
but that's not what it originally was
well it only I mean the story only
started really I think the earliest one
was like 1995 or so there like that
started in Puerto Rico right yeah and
then kind of a bread yeah then it spread
to other places I know I did my teenage
years in South America when you know a
South American culture in Central
American culture there's a lot of
comfortably and a lot of macumba and a
lot of imagination South America's have
fantastic imaginations they love a good
story
and they like to leak [ __ ] up they just
do and we all here we all make sure but
this I don't believe that there was it
you know of course there was no
shibukawa no but there was just all
predation yeah normal predation and
farmers and farm people like to tell a
story of what it was because they didn't
actually get a good look at it because
predators are pretty quick specially
nocturnal predators the chances of you
actually catching one well it's probably
pretty slammed you like you'd hear
something going on the chicken coop and
by the time you got outside with your
flashlight it's gone
yeah and then you find the wounded
animals right the thing about chupacabra
is like every time somebody says they've
caught a chupacabra they filmed a
superpower so it always just a quick dog
I'm like what city with the headline I
was like a dog wolf or dog coyote hi but
even that this big deal that's not even
if it was like a dog coyote hybrid so
what well there was never a chupacabra
yeah that's my idea was just I'm like I
want to see the full on things the so I
put it back in the foot now that was
just the story of the shoe bomber such a
disappointment I'm always like expecting
more but so actually it's so like a
better kind of wear creature story now I
kind of like this one the goat man of
Maryland now this is suppose this is
like more of a if we do this is right
yeah we did yeah remember we did it
before we started talking about the neck
exam oh you're losing mine that's okay
my family it happens when you get old
kids something to look forward to
would be ashame what's going on I don't
know what's going on
oh right oh yeah that's going to be on
every show now yeah but yes there are no
like we're raccoons though are there no
yeah no half man half rock out now okay
so we're going to have to settle for
half man half goat now this is a good
story goat man in Maryland now this is
kind of more like a 50 sci-fi type of
cryptid right because apparently the
goat man of Maryland used to be a person
he was a scientist and much like Jeff
Goldblum in the fly he was experimenting
with goats what he was doing with them
I don't know but somehow his DNA in the
DNA of a goat became entangled and he
turned into a half-man half-goat now for
some reason after he turned into a
half-man half-goat he got an axe and
started running around terrorizing
people and chopping on people's cars and
things like that now the weird thing
about this story is that there's another
one in Texas called the Lake Worth
monster who is also a half-man half-goat
and who also jumps out of trees and
tears up cars
what do half-man half-goat have against
cars well no one professional football
start the stories horseshit that's not
yeah no kidding that's not an original
story that's stories of satyrs yes later
that's all what they're talking about
was like pan you know and the reason why
it's attacking cars because it attacked
a person there'd be a victim left behind
and then yeah and then wouldn't and who
that would entail evidence but if you
attack a car
the story doesn't require any evidence
yeah you can just chop up your own sock
David arpaia from his car got chopped up
he said well this person got chopped up
a little where's the police report yeah
see yeah that's true okay so that's why
okay so other than you get all [ __ ]
where it is well yeah that was some kids
salsa sauce some Roman statues and Roman
depictions of tan and satyrs and things
like that and they went oh man those
mice really be real let's make up story
yeah you know there's also some reports
of lizard men reptilians and considering
like all the reptilian conduct
conspiracy theories of surprise there's
not more of these but actually the kind
of
one guy with the reptilians right with
the David Icke II yeah yeah there's only
one guy but this but the cryptid ones
are different because this one I mean
the lizard man in skateboard scores
escape or swamp excuse me that's from
South Carolina and this is supposedly a
bipedal rep selling much like a slew SEC
I guess group that's how I'm picturing
him felt seven feet saw glowing red eyes
now he has dark hair over must his body
too so a hairy lizard and I whatever
that was actually first seen in 1988 and
there was one also seen in Canada in
1972 and that's called the Fed it's lake
monster and he supposedly looks like the
gill man you know from Creature from the
Black Lagoon
you know not as many lizard creatures as
I would have thought however there is in
Ohio there is a creature called the
Loveland frog and as you might imagine
this is a four foot tall bipedal frog
and it looked in every drawing I've ever
seen because obviously no one's taken
photographs it's a every picture I've
seen of it has looked like just a big
frog standing on two legs it's not like
a half man/half frog
it's just like a big frog standing on
two legs okay so this this comes from
1955 and this man reported actually not
just seeing one Loveland frog seeing
three frog people as standing on the
side of the road this is a 1955 and a
police officer said that he saw a the
Loveland Frog in 1972 now at the last
sighting of it and this kind of cracked
me up the most recent sighting of it was
in 2016 and it was two teenagers who are
playing Pokemon go and they saw the
Loveland frog
now the Loveland Frog is so famous in
Ohio that apparently somebody wrote a
musical called hot damn it's the level
of rock and I was like oh my god I so
have to write what's the next one
alright so we also had bird-like
creatures we got Mothman uh which you
know that's that's kind of been covered
he just kind of looked like a big moth a
large flying man with 10-foot wings
basically there's one end Cornwall
England called the owl man which is kind
of similar big feathered a big feathered
guy there's also one in the Congo and
western Zambia called the kongamato and
that actually looks more like a
pterodactyl or a pterosaur rather which
actually that's not
- I don't know I don't know probably
like a leftover from maybe our racial
memory or so no I don't believe any
stories from Africa yeah you know why
because any [ __ ] as well just can go to
Africa and those black guys over there
are good are gonna have fun with it and
say oh yeah we've seen that I would take
you right there where that is oh yeah
well that's what I would damn sure
thinking that they're gonna mess that
détente let's mess with the white yeah
is what mess with the white people
now there's also known I never heard of
this one even though this is an American
one the Sonali gaster and that's
surprised this is from the DC Frederick
County Maryland area now this one is
kind of like it's a big bird but it's
kind of like a dragon type of thing
half-reptile half bird with like a sort
of metal beak with teeth in it and
occasionally tentacles and usually in
all the artwork I think the tentacles
were like coming out of its mouth or
sometimes they're coming out of the
bottom of it or whatever and apparently
it has a mortal enemy called the do a OH
or do i oh and that's kind of like a
werewolf and they fight all the time I
don't know why that is so it's like this
bird creature and his werewolf creature
and they're fighting so I don't know I
had actually never heard of that one
before
so that was kind of a weird one also one
in the Congo and this one is not really
like I said this one's not really that
crazy it's called the the Jim Bako fee
which is supposedly it's just a big-ass
fighter it's must be four to six feet
across but you know what I've seen crabs
that big yeah king crab I could buy that
I could buy a rental spider can't get
that big the chitin doesn't doesn't work
well there they didn't be too soft it
would just collapse that was just came
from somebody's imagination or it was
some kind of old-timey misidentification
of an elastic laughing King or some Jer
our Tolkien kind of like that helmet up
like that yeah now this this last couple
minutes of the show I kind of wanted to
get into the more fun ones like these
kind of dudes are like the what the [ __ ]
hybrid model there's these other was
worthwhile cities other ones won't work
the [ __ ] they're less what the [ __ ] okay
because okay like you know what I mean
werewolf you know it doesn't exist but
it's not crazy it's not that crazy no
that's crazy I mean it's great it's not
crazy and that it's
you know it's something that most people
have come up with it's um you know with
half man half hour whatever alright
these other ones I don't know where the
hell this shit's coming from the Jersey
Devil for example yeah yeah that's a lot
of longer walking beer and yeah and this
is like New Jersey right yeah and this
is described as a kangaroo light
creature has a goat head bat wings horn
little arm claws cloven hooves and a
forked tail when did this story come
from now see ok now that's another thing
yeah when does this story appear well it
was first reported in the 1700 s the
most recent sighting I found was the
1993 of course ranger study thoughts
confirmed no I'm just saying that's the
first mention of the first mention it
was 70 within the 1700 and it is being
mentioned on 1700 parchment or is this a
book from the 99 how would I know I bet
[ __ ] I need to know more information is
this a book of the 1980s the 1970s
saying oh we found a book from the 1700s
it has this monster in it right because
that happens a lot in this dish well
yeah I know you know I would really be
skeptical no but I know that well I
think the story is probably from here's
the davines so wait the way you're
approaching this as though I'm saying
this [ __ ] exists I know they don't know
this no I know I'm not saying that
they're real I know that I know I'm just
saying I would like to see the source
material the sort of measure of where
that story came I'm sure you bet you
that stories from this from the 70s how
much it is well probably and cuz you
know the big itch I should generate
Jersey knows how troll well I needed no
natural I should note that the highest
incidence of Jersey Devil sightings was
in 1960 was it okay yes that's when it
was muralha it's probably but I'm just
wondering like what like whose bat wings
like a cow hat or go ahead wet what is
it like the day he's supposed to be the
devil right
Gaber troll but speaking of like horse
creatures honestly the Philippines they
have the best monster the field well
Japan's pretty good too but Philippines
had the best they have the most what the
[ __ ] monsters case in point the tick
bilang which is like a where
course but he's going to live like up in
the mountains and stuff and he's like a
humanoid he's like tall and bony and
he's got really really long arms and
legs but then he has a horse head and
horse feet now in some versions of the
tickling legend he started out as an
aborted fetus but he was sent back to
earth from limbo in that form for some
reason now the tick blank if you get yes
like spine sticking out of the neck if
you can get three of those spines out of
his neck then he'll like be your slave
like you can tell them to do stuff and
he'll do it like he'll be your sir like
a genie lit yeah he's like a genie so
he's not mean necessarily another weird
one and this is from Aboriginal
mythology as the Bunya the weird thing
about the bunyip is that there's really
no universally accepted description of
what a bunion is like the first
description of it that I could find like
in the literature and stuff like that
said it actually looked like a big huge
starfish of all things hmm but usually
like the later drawings and stuff like
that that said it was a bunion it
usually looks like it has like a dog
face like a head kind of like a
crocodile and it has like fur then it
has a horse tail flippers tusks and
horns like it's like a big huge platypus
kind of really sort of the way it's
described so I don't know what the hell
is the deal with that one that just
sounds like a generalized monster and
there's also South Africa has a good one
called the group slang
now the group slang is like half snake
half elephant if you can imagine that
yeah so it's usually I don't know
there's like a legend about it where the
gods were making creatures and they were
super high one day you guys and they
made a group flying and then they were
like what because that we can't have
that so they tried so they split it into
an elephant and a snake and they're like
all right that's good but one grootslang
escaped all right so now all the groups
Lang's that are still in the world like
ours are retired from that one okay but
they're usually shown is like either an
elephant with snakes on its face or just
like half snake half elephants that type
of thing and
also the cool thing about the group
flying it's kind of like a dragon in
that he's super into like gems and stuff
right
so you can get them to not eat you by
going hey I got all these diamonds you
can have these and don't eat me
okay now the last messed up when I
worked I was also from the Philippines
and this is actually kind of my favorite
one or favorite ones and that's the a
swag and that's that's actually not so
much one creature is like kind of a
class of creatures they're kind of like
a vampire where beast ghoul which wizard
type of thing where it's like they kind
of look like normal people most of the
time but then at night they can
shape-shift and they drink blood they
and the Philippines has like a bunch of
stuff about for some reason like a lot
of their monsters have really long
tongues and they want to like stick
their tongues in like pregnant women's
bellies and like eat the fetuses out or
like eat people's hearts and stuff
they're super into that kind of [ __ ]
yeah
so what's wrong with you Philippines
truck docks
oh yeah but the thing about the outlines
though is that if you're if you're
friends with them like or neighbors with
them like in their normal form then they
won't eat you it's almost over if they
only eat strangers for people they don't
like
now also associated with the aspirin it
may actually be a type of a slang is the
minaton gall and this is actually my
favorite one in this whole show I don't
you know this one obviously this cannot
exist this is usually shown as a female
not always but most of the time and it's
kind of like a it was like a herpe or a
vampire type thing the coolest thing
about the monana gall is that when she
goes out to hunt the top half of her
body
tears off of her bottom half yeah and
she grows she sprouts these big wings
and then she goes flying around like
sucking blood of eating babies and
whatnot it's exam part pretty much but I
don't but why does she leave her bottom
half behind because to make it more
better to make it more better yeah
because here's the thing though when she
leaves the her bottom half behind that
part is like super vulnerable and if you
come across the bottom half of a Madonna
girl and you [ __ ] it all up like you put
garlic or holy water I don't know or
something on it then she dies because
she can't get back onto her leg
yeah so I don't know like I don't know
what the point of that is just because
it's neat that they like the idea of
lysosome some crazy woman flying her out
with her intestine sex she's the story
today made uh I guess so but them that
was actually my favorite one that's why
I'm tempted till last yeah yeah Madeline
okay because there was us there were
also some cryptids on there that look
extremely plausible but they were like
normal
it's like yeah we saw a woodchuck it's
about the size of woodchuck a little bit
bigger than Scott stripes on just that
kind of stuff well see that's why
there's a lot of those that like I kind
of left a lot of those out because like
I said if there's exists everybody being
like big whoop yeah yeah you know I mean
oh it's a different kind of wolf oh it's
a different speed in a bear big gale
we've got stripes on it and this one
doesn't move there are also there's also
some stuff that's believed to be extinct
but now and then they claim they've seen
them like a Tasmanian wolf right
singling yeah thanks liked em a tiger
hood or you know things like that which
like I said you know I would be a little
bit surprised at that existed but not
super so I don't really consider that
I'll get it back down to that breeding
population yeah you have to have a big
enough breeding population to maintain a
species yeah and that always makes an
environmental impact it does yes always
so alright so as I feared we ran it
because I left out a lot of stuff that I
had in my own yeah you don't need just a
primer show we didn't take that ones
that I thought were yet you know ever
it's just a primer show cuz this is a
big subject it is yeah yeah I spent so
much time no practice into focusing just
on one of them you need a lot of
information that we don't have access
yeah pretty much yeah but um okay so
that'll do it for this week's episode
hope you enjoyed this very information
dense exploration as always if you like
our show please subscribe to our YouTube
channel or check out project
Entertainment Network like on Facebook
like on Facebook follow on Twitter all
of that good stuff on the t-shirts
yeah I keep forgetting to mention go to
zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock we have 5
different designs and there's also one
on the project Entertainment Network
store there's less a slightly different
one with the logo design
on it and you can check that one out too
and um you know make me a Snake Plissken
see okay I'll make you a Snake Plissken
t-shirt or may I'll get around to it one
already also like I said England
Australia's listeners if you want free
audiobook copies of any of my four
paranormal books then drop me a message
and I will send you a code I still have
a few codes left if you promise you're
going to review it yeah that's the whole
point of me giving them out yeah if
you've already done a review it's okay
you can contact it again we'll give you
another book that you haven't read yet
yeah where you haven't listened to you
yeah they're all of it yeah just let me
just let me know which one I gave you
and then I'll give you one of the other
ones if you liked it and you can review
another one too if you're into that and
that'll do it for episode 42 okay
alright yes you can believe the power of
the Box man busy busy
yes you can believe in the power of the
MA plan
well he's seven feet tall with eyes of
red and if you don't listen to him you
will end up dead he tried to warn
everybody yes he did about how they were
in danger from a broken bridge
[Music]
[Music]